[Music]
rachel is in san jose california hi
rachel welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for taking my call how
are you sure better than i deserve
what's up
um first i want to say thanks for taking
my call again i've been listening to you
since i've been in community college so
it's kind of cool to be on the show but
my question is how to save money for a
master's program specifically an mba i
plan on going back to school within the
next three years and the program i'm
looking at will be around 150 to 200 000
why for an mba
why would you pay that for an mba
it's a pretty prestigious school and
it's just
i couldn't give a crap less that's
ridiculous
there's no mba on the planet worth 150
grand
no
donald trump what if rachel what's your
what's your why for go for getting it
what's like the end goal you're getting
an mba to do what
um i want to be a leader in supply chain
and just be more well-rounded i know
within the field i'm in it's not
necessarily required but i've always
enjoyed school and hopefully by the time
i get to that point i can afford it and
it's not too much of a strain on my
budget how much do you make a year
um
well i'm right now making about 80 but i
just signed for a new job and i'll be
making around 150
and the sign on bonus will hopefully
clear my debt i have about 30 000
in
loans and debt so half of it's in my car
and half of it's in student loans
and where is your degree and you have a
degree in supply chain
um i actually studied finance but i
landed a job in supply chain and i
actually really loved it and you're
doing great okay so where is your
finance degree from what school
i actually went to a small school in the
midwest you you probably wouldn't have
heard of it but um but i want to say it
on air but i transferred from a
community college uh within the smallest
and and what did you pay for your
finance degree
uh it was thirty thousand dollars total
for two years since i transferred you're
amazing
rachel you're making exactly my point
you're making six grand you're making
fifty 150 dollars a year six figures
you're making a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year from a thirty
thousand dollar undergraduate finance
degree and the fact that you're a
hustler and you're smart and you know
how to grind and you jumped over into
supply chain which is a hot
career field especially right now you've
done everything smart to this point
until somebody told you that where you
went to school mattered and it does not
there is zero hard data zero hard data
on the planet that says where you go to
school matters
and you're proof of that that's true
you're proof of that
you should pay 20 grand for an mba
yeah the program actually the company
i'm working for does sponsor
like master's programs
full time they're going to pay for it no
i just
they're going to pay for you to go to
school and get your mba
yeah
but it's just not the school you picked
out
right okay so here's what we're gonna do
um i don't know if we have a way to do
this or not i want you to watch borrowed
future our documentary on student loan
debt tonight
i want you to watch it 200 000 people
have watched it on google play on apple
tv
on amazon prime and kelly can we give
her a code to watch borrowed future we
can okay good i'm going to give it to
you that way you don't have to pay for
the rental even okay we'll give you a
promo code and you can watch it for free
as my gift all right and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
sign up to
get a free mba that your company that
pays you a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year to do supply chain is
going to pay for at a school because i
gotta tell you
no one cares where you went to school
out here in the real world
all they know is you got an mba that's
all they know
right that's all they know
i got probably 40 or 50 maybe 60 mbas
working here at ramsey i couldn't tell
you where a single one of them went to
school and by the way i didn't even hire
them because they had an mba i hired
them because they passed our stringent
interview process and they proved to be
very studly people
and they fit into the ramsey program
here now when i'm sitting and talking to
them and i know they have an mba it's
helpful because i know how to
communicate because mbas are have a
certain
critical thinking skill thing that is
pretty much
germane to all of your fields of study
but oh my gosh i love it i want you to
go get the mba and i love that you like
studying but please please please please
learn something from your finance degree
it's called return on investment
you will make zero more money for
spending 150 than you will get in the
free one that your work will pay for
please
you're right dave
i'm begging you i was like dave's
begging her
please please please don't do this oh
but here but here's the mindset and i
feel like rachel that you're in that i
that i
we we hear it a lot though is when
you're in that academic world and you
love school i mean she said i love
studying i love you know i want to get
my mba all of these things
and you kind of get into that sector of
life where that's where people go
that people do applaud the nice school
you know like i understand rachel how
you got there because
it makes sense and i think that there
are people out there that put things on
a pedestal and all of that
but the re but you gotta get out the
reality here's the reality the reality
is
getting an mba is great when you can pay
for it
and the fact that your company will pay
for will completely pay for it it's free
it's free and rachel you you
are amazing
you're the secret sauce
not the nba not the degree and certainly
not where you got the degree
i mean i
i've never gone to a doctor and i go
where'd you go to school
i've never gone to a lawyer where'd you
go to school i've never asked them never
asked them i i've never hired an
accountant and said you know where'd you
go to school
i've hardly ever heard an employee if i
ask them where they went to school in an
interview it's just as a matter of
conversation but i've never hired
someone that went to x school over went
to y school yeah um
as a matter of fact it around here
it's kind of works against you
people that went to community college
and paid for it we're like you worked
your butt off yeah you're one of us yeah
you know you're a blue collar you get
her done baby you leave the cave kill
something and drag it home you're one of
us yeah that's right
it um
versus i paid you know a bazillion
dollars for a degree in left-handed
puppetry oh my gosh
you know so rachel you just got so much
on the ball you're just such a sharp
young woman i'm just begging you not to
make that mistake hang on kelly i'll
give you a copy or give you a code so
you can watch
borrowed
future seth godin our friend is one of
the leading marketing minds on the
planet will go off on these famous
schools
and he's he's mr data i mean he's
checked all the data on all of this and
he thinks it's the biggest prestigious
schools are the biggest scam
on the planet for what they cost now if
you get to go for free you know you have
a cousin that went to vanderbilt 100
free
free ride you know very smart got a
you know salutatory valedictorians type
scholarship sure go
but you know but you don't need to pay
10x for the same set of education
because of where where you're going to
school that's a really bad plan boys and
girls ladies and gentlemen